hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt
heute gibt es ein kleines basic video
und zwar wirklich lecker zubereiten
lemon gehört das ist eine zitronencreme
diebe nutzen wie zum beispiel als
brotaufstrich für torten füllungen oder
firma verfehlungen und ich habe auch
schon mal in der tat damit gefühlt also
richtig lecker das ist eine sehr
fruchtige creme weil eben viel zitrone
mit dabei ist man benutzt die
zitronenschale den zitronensaft und
ganze wieder mit ei und stärke gebunden
und ich zeige euch jetzt mal kurz hier
vorne die zutaten für das lernen hört
brauchen wir vier unbehandelte bio
zitrone 3 150 gramm zucker einen
teelöffel schweizer stellte und 40 gramm
butter und habe hier bereits zwei gläser
gerichtetes in einmachgläser und habe
einen kleinen topf und eine citrus
presse und einem schneebesen und hier
noch eine küchen reibe zum für die
zitronenschale und ansonsten braucht ihr
auch wirklich gar nichts an werkzeug
also es geht auch wirklich ganz schnell
und ich fange jetzt direkt an heute habe
ich ihn ansprach naja ich fange jetzt
direkt mit den zitronen an und zwar
reichlich jetzt erstmals zitronenschale
die zitronen habe ich natürlich vorher
heiß abgewaschen
bei der zitronenschale es ist ganz
wichtig dass sie das gelbe mit abreiten
des weißes sap.etr es nämlich die
zitronen und quetschte so ein bisschen
zusammen
dann kann man den saft nämlich besser
auspressen dahinten das schneide ich
immer ganz gern weg da kann ich besser
pressen und jetzt halt nächste und
drückt noch den zitronensaft aus es
sollten dann mindestens 150 milliliter
werden
den zitronensaft verrühren jetzt mit den
eiern drogba und gibt da auch direkt die
speisestärke mit dazu fühle ich alles in
einen kleinen topf da kann ich doch auch
etwas besser und früher auch direkt in
zucker mit ein
jetzt stehe ich den herd auf mittlere
stufe und lass das ganze dann etwa fünf
bis zehn minuten eindicken und zwar
sollte die masse jetzt nicht kochen
denn ansonsten kann es passieren dass
das ei gerinnt also immer schön rühr und
ganz vorsichtig eindicken machen
die konsistenz ist jetzt richtig also im
moment ist es noch etwas dünner aber
durchaus abkühlen wird jetzt auch etwas
dicker und ich streiche es jetzt einmal
durch ein sieb damit klümpchen auch
weggehen vom ei zum beispiel und ich
habe das jetzt auch so lange erhitzt
damit alle keime beim getötet werden
denn wir haben ja die masse nicht
aufkochen lassen dass er keine 100 grad
erreicht
und wenn man das eben fünf bis zehn
minuten lang erhitzt dann wird alles
abgetötet und dann ist er mit drin
und jetzt deckt das lernen könnt direkt
an der oberfläche mit etwas
frischhaltefolie ab und lass es für
ungefähr fünf minuten abkühlen
das ist nicht mehr ganz so heiß und da
kann ich gleich viel butter einrühren
fertig machen
das ist noch ein bisschen wärmer als
lauwarm gebe ich die butter in kleine
stückchen mit dazu level kann es von der
konsistenz sehr cremig dafür sorgt ja
auch das eigelb da drinnen und die
butter macht es dann auch schön glänzend
und dadurch jetzt auch ein bisschen
fester
wenn ich jetzt lernen gehört als torten
füllung benutzen möchte zum beispiel wie
so eine art buttercreme nehme ich
einfach etwas mehr runter weil dann mehr
die butter noch mal schön fest und das
lernen könnt ihr dann auch richtig
festina torte ich mag es so als
brotaufstrich auch also genau man kann
es jetzt wie gesagt als torten aufstrich
benutzen man kann es als trocken füllung
benutzen als martin füllung oder was ich
auch ganz leger finde einfach ein
bisschen quark nehmen ein paar esther
für level könnt mit rein geben so viel
wie man leben möchte und es dann einfach
so essen
also ich find es ist ein allrounder
fähig auch man kann sagen die arme
reiben kann man auch ich finde immer
ganz gerne eine kleine gläschen ab so
kann man sie nämlich gut funktionieren
und man kann es auch toll verschenken
man sollte dann nur unbedingt drauf
schreiben wie lange sie noch haltbar
sind also im kühlschrank würde ich sie
nicht länger als eine woche aufheben
weil da ist ja auch ein mit drin weil
sie auch butter mit drin und die butter
wird irgendwann sich also man kann jetzt
nicht so lange aufheben wie marmelade
zum beispiel aber ich habe auch schon
gehört dass müsse einfrieren kann so kam
es bei uns irgendwie noch nie dazu weil
das land gehört eigentlich immer direkt
aufgefordert wird und ich will es auch
nicht
ich finds auch die einfälle
zum glasbecher ja im glas sowieso nicht
einfrieren also wenn es eins gehen
möchte dann auf keinen fall in dem glas
er dann in kunststoff genug ich
verschließe sitzt und dann gebe ich den
kühlschrank sobald es abgekühlt ist wie
gesagt eine woche haltbar wäre das
rezept nach machen wollt geht auch janis
minins block der stets nochmal und ihr
könnt es natürlich auch ausdrucken und
will das nachmacht freue ich mich über
ein foto wenn ihr mit dieser facebook
oder instagram sendet und mich dabei
markiert also viel spaß beim nachmachen
und bis zum nächsten mal
man kann es aber man kann das ein weg ja
was sollte man kann auch mit dem fahrrad
im friseurladen reinfahren
aber was sollte man